ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA BROUGH. BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. REVEREND PATTY OSHA
URBAN OSHA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. WITH AN
AVERAGE DAILY TEMPERATURE OF
ALMOST NINETY FIVE DEGREES THE
SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
HAS BECOME THE THIRD HOTTEST
SACRAMENTO SUMMER EVER RECORDED.
LONG HEAT WAVES REMIND ME OF
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA SUMMERS
OF MY CHILDHOOD. IN FRESNO WE
DREADED THE SUMMER HEAT FOUR IN
THE EVENING TEMPERATURES RARELY
COOL. BUT ON A SPECIALLY
SWELTERING UNCOMFORTABLE NIGHTS
MY MOM WOULD SIT BAR THAT SIDE
IN FAN HER THREE CHILDREN TO
SLEEP. THIS REMAINS A LOVING
MEMORY OF MY MOTHER THAT I WILL
ALWAYS CHERISH. IT IS ALSO A
REMINDER THAT EVERY DAY RAIN OR
SHINE UNDER BILLY HOT OR
SHIVERING COLD WITH OUR ACTS OF
LOVING KINDNESS WE CAN CREATE
MEMORIES THAT WILL LIVE ON IN
THE HEARTS OF OUR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WELL BEYOND OUR
LIFETIMES. AS OUR SUMMER COMES
TO A CLOSE LET'S TRY TO FIND
TIME TO ENJOY THESE TOASTY WARM
DAYS AND COMFORTABLE EVENINGS
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE
WILL THINK OF THEM FROM THE
WHEN THE COLD WINTER DAYS
ARRIVE. NOW MOMMY NUMBER TWO
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS. THANK YOU
REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE. JOIN ME AS WE
SALUTE OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE UNITED STATES
OR- AND. WHEN ASIAN. VISIBLE
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY AUGUST
NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN ISN'T
ON THAT AT ONE PM I WILL KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THIS
ON THE PRESIDING CHIEF COOKIE
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DANCER
BONTA MOVES IN MISTER FLORA
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE
. MOVING TO MOTIONS.
AND RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S
ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM
CALDERON IN LIMON FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMACK
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS SERVE ON CASE AND
WALDRON MR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THEN
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO
ALLOW SOME MEMBERS COOLEY AND
WHEN TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
PATTERSON BROKE MAIENSCHEIN
KILEY AND COOPER TO SPEAK ON
MANAGEMENT IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PLEASE MOVE ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT HILL TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE ACTION WHEREBY SB
TWO OH TWO WILK. WELL AS READ A
THIRD TIME AND AMENDED ON
SEPTEMBER FIFTH TWENTY NINETEEN.
THAT MATCHED THE CLERK WILL
NOTE WITHOUT OBJECTION. I MOVE
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINE TO ALLOW THE ADOPTION OF
LATE FLOOR AMENDMENTS ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ITEM NUMBER ONE
FIFTY SB FIFTY FOUR GONZALEZ I
REMEMBER NO ONE NINETY ONE SB
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT CERVANTES AND
ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTY TWO SB
FOUR SEVEN TWO LIMA MR FLORA
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOUR EYES.
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT AS FOR ROLL CALL OKAY.
MR BONTA IS MOVING TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO TAKE UP LATE
AMENDMENTS. MR FOR IT IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENTS.
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISS WORK
SECONDS. WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS MODE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
SIX FORTY ONE. WORK WILL. CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
MEASURE THE MOTION IS ADOPTED.
MR BOUNTY ORGAN RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU. MA'AM SPEAKER THERE
IS A LIST OF BILLS AT THE DESK
WITH FLOOR AMENDMENTS PENDING I
ASK THAT THE READING CLERK READ
THE BILLS THAT WE ADOPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT THEY GO OUT
TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE.
HEARING NO OBJECTION THE CLERK
WILL READ THE BILL'S WITH
AMENDMENTS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO ASSEMBLED FORTY
SIXTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS BY
MCCARTY. BY NINETY THREE SENATE
BILL THIRTY SIX WITH THE
MOMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER. FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX
CYNICAL FORTY SEVEN WITH THE
MEMONS BY SOMETHING OR MULLIN.
FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY FIVE WITH THE
MEMONS BY FAMILY MEMBER WOULD.
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN SAID
ABOUT THREE SEVENTY SEVEN WITH
THE MEMONS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE. FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE
SYLLABLE FIVE NINETY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE. FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
NINE SIMPLE FIVE FIFTY WITH A
MOMENT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
HOLDEN. FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
ONE SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY NINE
WITH THE MEMBERS BY SOMETHING
MEMBERS DONE. BOTTOM ONE THREE
TWO SENATE BILL SIX NINETY WITH
THE MEMBERS BY SELLING MEMBER
GLORIA. FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
TWO SIMPLE SEVEN FORTY TWO WITH
THE MEMBERS BY SELLING
EMIGRATE. BOTTOM ONE THIRTY
FOUR SYMBOL FIVE SIXTY WITH THE
MEMBERSBY SOMETHING MEMBER
WOULD. BUY AND ONE THIRTY EIGHT
SIMPLE FIVE NINETY TWO WITH THE
MEMONS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
DAVID CHIU. FIND ONE THIRTY
NINE SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
SIX WITH THE MEMONS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY THREE SENATE BILL SIX
WITH THE MEMONS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. BY ADAM
ONE FORTY FOUR SENATE BILL
EIGHT WITH THE MEMONS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SIX SENATE BILL
TWENTY FOUR WITH THE MEMONS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. BOTTOM.
ONE SIXTY. SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY NINE WITH THE MEMONS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA. BOTTOM
ONE SIXTY NINE SAID ABOUT THREE
SIXTY THREE WITH THE MEMONS
WITH BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. BOTTOM ONE
SEVENTY TWO SAID ABOUT THREE
SEVENTY SIX WITH THE MEMONS BY
SOME A MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN.
BOTTOM ONE SEVENTY FOUR SAID
ABOUT THREE NINETY FIVE WITH
THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING OVER
AGUIAR-CURRY. BOTTOM ONE EIGHTY
FIVE SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT WITH THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
BOTTOM ONE EIGHTY SIX IN ABOUT
FIVE FORTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SONY MEMBER OR WHEN. BOTTOMONE EIGHTY SEVEN SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT WITH THE
MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY NINE SENATE BILL FIVE
SEMI SIXTH AMENDMENTS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
BY ADAM ONE NINETY ONE SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WITH THE
MEMONS BY SO MANY MEMBERS
CERVANTES. FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
THREE SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX
WITH THE MOMENT BY SOMETHING
MEMBER LO. FI AND ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN CYNICAL SIX TWENTY WITH
THE MEMBERS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GIPSON. FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED
SAID WELL SIX THIRTY THREE WITH
THE MEMONS BASED ON THE NUMBER
QUIRK. FILE ITEM TO A TO SYMBOL
SIX SIX EIGHT WITH THE MEMONS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY. FILE
ITEM TO A SYMBOL THIRTEEN WITH
THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
VOEPEL. BY AM TO ELEVEN SAID
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR WITH THE
MEMONS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
WOULD. FILE ITEM TO FOURTEEN
CYNICAL FIFTY EIGHT WITH A
MOMENT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
SANTIAGO. FILE ITEM TO FIFTEEN
CYNICAL SIXTY ONE WITH THE
MOMENT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. BOTTOM TO NINETEEN
CYNICAL ONE THREE TWO WITH THE
MEMONS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
STONE. FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
THREE SIMPLE ONE FORTY TWO WITH
THE MEMBERS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
WICKS. BOTTOM TO TWENTY EIGHT
SYMBOL WANTS ME TO WITH THE
MOMENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
FIVE TO THIRTY SIX AND ABLE TO
TEN WITH THE MOMENT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
BOTTOM TO THIRTY SEVEN SYMBOL
TO EIGHTEEN WITH THE MEMONS BY
SO MANY MEMBER KALRA FINE TO
FORTY EIGHT SYMBOL TO THIRTY
SEVEN WITH THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. BOTTOM
TO FIFTY SIMPLE THREE THIRTY
SEVEN WITH A MOMENT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER RUBIO. BOTTOM
TO FIFTY SIX AT ABOUT FORTY ONE
WITH THE MEMBERS BY SONY MEMBER
BURKE. BOTTOM TO SIXTY MONTHS
BEFORE SOME THE ONE WITH THE
MEMBERS BASED ON THE NUMBER
IRWIN. BOTTOM TO CITY TUESDAY
BEFORE CITY TO AT THE MOMENT
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER LOW MOAN.
BOTTOM. TWO SIX AND SAID ABOUT
FIVE THIRTY WITH THE MINUTES
SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO. FILE
I'M TO SEVENTY EIGHT SIMPLE
SEVEN OH FOUR WITH THE MENACE I
SOME LIMITED WATER GARCIA. BOND
TO EIGHTY THREE SYMBOL TO
EIGHTY SIX WITH THE MOMENT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO. BY ON
TWO EIGHTY FIVE SYMBOL FIVE
EIGHTY SIX WITH THE MINUTES
BASICALLY MEMBER HOLDEN. AND
FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY SIX AT
ABOUT THREE NINETY NINE WITH A
MEMBERS BASED ON THE NUMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE BILLS ARE OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK TO FILE. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING ITEM NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
JONES SAWYER TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION.
IN A MOMENT. GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY PRIVILEGE
TODAY TO HONOR THE SAN MONTERO
ON THE OCCASION OF HER
RETIREMENT AFTER THIRTY SIX
YEARS OF SERVICE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND. IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE IS A PART OF THIS TO
SAY YOU KNOW IT'S AN HONOR TO
SERVE HERE'S OUR FIRST TO SERVE
ON THIS FLOOR. WE COMMEND THIS
TO SWITCH SERVE DILIGENTLY. BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY VERY SMALL SUBSET
OF PEOPLE EVER WORK IN THIS
BUILDING TO WHOM IT COULD BE
SAID SERVICE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL IS IN THEIR BLOOD.
BECAUSE IT HAD A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO SERVED HERE. HER FATHER
JOHNNY MONTERO WAS JUST SIMPLY
SERGEANT NEIL DAY. AND I KNEW
JOHNNY MONTERO. I HE WAS
ACTUALLY CLOSE FRIENDS TO MY
BOSS LOOP HAPPEN SO IT'S FUNNY
WHEN I SAW THE SAN MONTERO WAS
RETIRING AND LOSE YOUR FATHER I
THOUGHT. SURELY THIS IS NOT
JOHNNY'S. AND SO I KRISTER BACK
HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND SHE
SAYS YEAH MY DAD'S NAME IS JOHN.
SO SHE HAS THIS INSTITUTION IN
HER BLOOD. DESIGN MONTERO WAS
BORN AND RAISED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND THEREFORE SAW
THE BUILDING AS A CHILD IN THE
COMPANY OF HER FATHER. TO
DEVOTE HIMSELF TO THIS WAR SHE
BEGAN HER CAREER IN THIS HOUSE
IN SEPTEMBER OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE IN HISTORICAL SERVICES
UNIT. THEN JOIN IN THE MAIL
ROOM OPERATION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AS A MAIL CLERK ONE.
BECAUSE ROSS ANY PERFORMANCE IN
THAT JOB SHE WAS PROMOTED TO
MAIL PER TO. RESPOND FOR
BOOKKEEPING BILLION FILING
DATABASE UPDATES MAIL
PROCESSING. AND BY NINETEEN
NINETIES WHO'S A SUPERVISOR IN
THE MAIL ROOM CLIMBING IN THE
ORGANIZATION. IN ADDITION
RESEARCH THE STATE ASSEMBLY SHE
HAS DEVOTED HER TIME TO
VOLUNTEER AND LOCAL ANIMAL
SHELTERS LGBT Q. SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE. SHE ALSO
FINANCES FORCE THE PEDIATRIC
BURN CENTER AT SHRINERS
HOSPITAL. CLOSE TO THE HOME OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO.
OF THE SOCIETY FOR THE
PREVENTION OF CRUELTY TO
ANIMALS LAW ENFORCEMENT
CHAPLAINCY OF SACRAMENTO. AND
NUMEROUS VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS.
AND IT'S JUST A PRIVILEGE
HAVING KNOWN THE FATHER TO
HONOR THE DAUGHTER OF THIS DAY
FOR HER SERVICE TO THIS BODY.
FURTHER A LONG TRADITION OF OUR
CIVIL. SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT ARE
DELIVER DEMOCRACY. SHE IS
JOINED TODAY BY HER CORE
WORKERS COME ALL WRONG
MICROPHONE VINCE LATINO KYLE
THE YOUNG AND FRIENDS OF FAMILY
CURRENTLY ON MOON ROLE KAREN
MEANS ROSE HILTON AND DANIELLE
JOHNSON SO I'D LIKE IT'S ALMOST
AND A. HAPPY RETIREMENT.
MONTERO
. MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO MR ONE MR
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
GUEST INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MATT. I RISE TODAY FOR THE%
PURPOSE OF RECOGNIZING MY
INCREDIBLE CHIEF OF STAFF THIS
IS JANICE LANDLORDS WHO IS
RETIRING LATER THIS YEAR AFTER
A DECADE OF OUTSTANDING SERVICE
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY WHEN WE COME HERE AS A
BRAND NEW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ONE
OF THE FIRST BIG DECISIONS WE
HAVE TO MAKE IS WHO IS GOING TO
BE OUR CHIEF OF STAFF AND IT'S-
IT IS ONE THAT REALLY AFFECTS
YOU THROUGHOUT YOUR ENTIRE TERM
AND I AM SO FORTUNATE THAT I
PICKED EXACTLY THE PERSON WITH
THE RIGHT FIT. SUSANNA IS SMART
AND WITTY AND INSIGHTFUL AND
ONE OF OUR BEST QUALITIES IS
SHE IS A EVELYN WOOD'S SPEED
READER SO IF ANYBODY HERE
THINKS THEY CAN GET ANYTHING BY
OUR OFFICE YOU ARE MISTAKEN.
AFTER JOINING THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAN BUCHANAN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AS HER DISTRICT
DIRECTOR SUSANNAH BECAME AN
INVALUABLE PART OF MY TEAM WHEN
I WAS IN LIFE WHEN I WAS
ELECTED IN THE TWENTY FOURTEEN
BY BECOMING MY CHIEF OF STAFF.
SHE JOINED THE ASSEMBLY AFTER
AN ALREADY IMPRESSIVE RECORD OF
PUBLIC SERVICE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHERE SHE FOUGHT FOR
ADEQUATE LIBRARY RESOURCES AND
QUALITY HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
SHE WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL IT TO
THE INCORPORATION OF THE TOWN
OF DANVILLE AND SHE LATER
SERVED ON THE CITY COUNCIL AND
AS ITS MAYOR. EVERYONE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO WORK
ALONGSIDE SUSANNA KNOWS THAT
SHE POSSESSES ALL THE QUALITIES
ONE COULD HOPE FOR IN A PUBLIC
SERVANT. HER EXPERIENCE FOUGHT
HOMELESS AND UNWAVERING
LEADERSHIP HAVE GREATLY
BENEFITED MY STAFF. MYSELF AS A
LEGISLATOR AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE RESIDENTS OF THE FORTY
FOURTH DISTRICT. SUSANNA HAS
ALWAYS PROVIDED A CALM STEADY
VOICE OF REASON AND COMPASSION
EVEN IN THE MIDST OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT OF CIRCUMSTANCES. I
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK HER FROM THE BOTTOM OF
MY HEART FOR ALL THAT SHE HAS
DONE. WHILE I'M SAD THAT OUR
RELATIONSHIP. AS CO WORKERS IS
COMING TO AN END I HAVE GAMES A
LIFELONG FRIEND I WISH YOU ALL
THE BEST AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SPENDING TIME AND I HOPE THAT
YOU. ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SPENDING TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY
AND YOUR HUSBAND AND THEN OR
AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
. AND SUZANNE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTEEN AND THE CITY OF
DANVILLE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR SERVICE. TO THE
COMMUNITY I REPRESENTS
. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM RE
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT SB
FIVE NINETY TWO WIENER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ITEM NUMBER ONE
NINETY THREE SB SIX SIX GLAZER
TO THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED ASK SIX THIRTY EASTERN
TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO SB
FOUR SEVENTY TWO CABALLERO TO
BANKING AND FINANCE. ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE SB TWO
EIGHTY SIX BY THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANISED GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE TO THE
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
TAKE OF SOME BILLS FOR PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY SB SIX SIXTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIX SIXTEEN WITH A MOMENT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER THREE OF US.
THIS RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS SB SIX ONE SIX PROTECT
THE MINIMAL AMOUNT IN
CALIFORNIANS BANK ACCOUNTS FROM
SEIZURE BY DEBT COLLECTORS
THESE NARROWING AMENDMENTS MAKE
EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT THE
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL CANNOT
BE ADDED ON TOP OF ANY OTHER
PROTECTIONS. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MS RIVAS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
MATTER WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. PHONE NUMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE NEWS FOURTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK TO FILE. BACK ON
FILE. USE ME. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SB FIFTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIFTY FOUR WITH THE MEMONS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ. MISS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS ON SB FIFTY
FOUR TO PHASE OUT SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS FIRST THESE AMENDMENTS
WOULD CREATE CLARITY FOR BOTH
CAL RECYCLING BUSINESS IS BY
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF PRODUCTS
COVERED TO SPECIFIC FOOD
SERVICE WHERE. IT MORE CLEARLY
SPELLING OUT THE OBLIGATIONS OF
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT AND
RETAILERS SECOND THE AMENDMENTS
BETTER CONFORM THIS BILL WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS THEY
STREAMLINED THE CREATION OF
WASTE REDUCTION BASS LINE WITH
EXISTING WASTE CHARACTERIZATION
STUDIES IN TAKING ACCOUNT
PRODUCERS THAT ARE ALREADY
IMPROVING RECYCLABILITY UNDER
THE BOTTLE BILL IN THE
REGULATORY FEE. WHICH IS
ESTABLISHED TO FIND THE
WORKLOAD OF THE DEPARTMENT
AMENDMENTS ALSO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT BALANCES
BY ESTABLISHING AN INDEPENDENT
PANEL WITH STAKEHOLDER
REPRESENTATIVES TO CONSULTANT
ADVICE CAL RECYCLE THROUGHOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
REGULATIONS IN IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL AND CREATED
ADICIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF LEGISLATURE. A
FURTHER PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY BY
ALLOWING RECYCLE TO LOWER THE
REQUIRED RECYCLING RATES IN THE
BILL I KNOW MORE THAN 10%
REQUIRED RATE TO BE ASSESSED IN
CONSULTATION STAKEHOLDER PANEL
THREE TWO YEARS. LASTLY THE
AMAZON. CARD RECYCLING RATES
MATERIAL NEUTRAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE BILL DOESN'T PICK WINNERS
AND LOSERS AMONG PACKAGING
TYPES AND CREATE GUIDELINES FOR
LOCAL ORDINANCES TO ENSURE
THEIR COLLECTION OF
INFRASTRUCTURE KEEPS UP WITH
PACKAGING REQUIREMENTS. WITH
EASE THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION IS NOW IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND SEVERAL OTHER
GROUPS ARE LOOKING TO MOVE
NEUTRAL OR SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TWENTY MINUTES. THANK YOU
MISS GONZALES WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A ROLL CALL AND THESE
AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS IS ON AMENDMENTS
MEMBERS AND IT REQUIRES FORTY
ONE MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT
AND VOTING WELL IF YOU HAVE ANY
PRESENT ARE PRESENT. SEVEN TWO
ZERO FIVE. A MAN. MEMBERS THIS
REQUIRES A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PRESENT AND VOTING THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLL EYES THIRTY
THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THEY'RE
OUT TO PRINT IN BACK ON FILE.
MOVING TO. FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY
ONE SB SEVEN FORTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SEVEN FORTY NINE WITH THE
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. IT'S GONZALEZ YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU AS
THESE AMENDMENTS OUT A
PROVISION THAT ALLOW A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR RECEIVING A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY TO CLAIM TRADE SECRET
PROTECTION FOR INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN PUBLIC CONTRACTS
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THE MA'AM IT'S ALSO
INCORPORATE. PROTECTIONS FOR
COMMUNICATION AND INFORMATION
RELATED TO NAP MATTERS OF
NATIONAL SECURITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. AGAIN THIS
REQUIRES A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PRESENT IN VOTING THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
AYE AYES THIRTY FIVE NEWS
FIFTEEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED. HOW TO PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE
. MR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY NINE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY TO TAKE UP LATE
FLOOR AMENDMENTS TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO THIRTY SB ONE EIGHTY TWO
JACKSON. MR FLORA WE WITH
WILLIAMS CONSENT AS A ROLL CALL
VOTE HEY MISTER. DANTE IS
MOVING TO S. SUSPEND THE FAMILY
RULES FOR A LATE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS MISTER BONTA MOVES.
AND THIS WAY X. SECONDS. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO THIRTY THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MISTER
BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR AN
NO VOTES. THIS IS A MOTION TO
SUSPEND THE RULES MISTER BONTA
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. BUT THERE'S ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR DEVOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESERT VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN NEWS FOURTEEN THE
MOTION IS ADOPTED
. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO. TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIRTY FOR PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS SB ONE EIGHTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY TWO WITH THE
MEMONS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. IS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO THE CLARIFY THE USE
OF CONSERVATION EASEMENTS AND
ADDING CHAPTER IN LANGUAGE I
ASKED FOR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. WE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
MATTER WE ARE GOING TO TAKE. I
WILL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS
GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE WHICH I FORTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE
. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
SEPTEMBER NINTH THERE'S A FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM. BUT I IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR
. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY
. MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY. MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMANY MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER END UP
MEMBERS. A BELOVED. VERY YOUNG
AND HIGHLY REGARDED. COMMUNITY
MEMBER AND. SYSTEM BASEBALL
COACH AT FRESNO CITY COLLEGE
SAM FLORES PASSED AWAY. ON
MONDAY OF THIS WEEK. HE
SUFFERED A SUDDEN BRAIN
ANEURYSM HE WAS ONLY FORTY ONE
YEARS OLD. BUT IN THOSE SHORT
FORTY ONE YEARS YEAH HI. SAM
CREATED A LEGACY OF.
PROFESSIONALISM. OF CARE FOR
HIS STUDENTS. PRIOR TO COACHING
AT FRESNO CITY COLLEGE HI HE
SPENT FOURTEEN YEARS AS A P.
TEACHER IN FRESNO UNIFIED
COACHED AT SEVERAL LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOLS. ALTHOUGH HIS PASSION
WAS ATHLETICS THE STUDENTS AND-
THESE YOUNG PLAYERS THAT HE
MENTORED. HIS LIFE. WAS HIS
FAMILY. ANDREA THEIR TWO
CHILDREN CLAIRE AND CAL. AND
OUR HEARTS ARE HEAVY WITH THEM
AND FOR THEM. LOVINGLY KNOWN AS
COACH FLOW. AS PLAYERS CALLED
HIM SO MUCH MORE THAN A
BASEBALL COACH. HE WAS A MENTOR
HE WAS A FRIEND HE WAS THE
BIGGEST CHEERLEADER FOR THOSE
YOUNG BASEBALL PLAYERS
IMAGINABLE. HE WOULD BE AT THE
FIELD EARLY HE WOULD LEAVE LATE
AND THE IMPACT ON THESE PLAYERS
WAS. MARCO BALL AND NOT JUST
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOOD BASEBALL
PLAYERS BUT HE WAS HELPING TO
MOLD THEM INTO GOOD HUMAN
BEINGS. COUNTLESS CURRENT AND
FORMER PLAYERS SAY THEY WOULD
NOT BE WHERE THEY ARE IN LIFE
TODAY IF IT WERE NOT FOR. COACH
FLOW. FRESNO CITY COLLEGE HEAD
COACH RON SCOTT SAID SAM
BROUGHT NEW LIFE TO THE FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE BASEBALL TEAM AND
THAT REALLY IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. COACH FLOOR I
JUST GOT A IS GOING TO BE
REALLY MISSED BY HIS LOVED ONES
BY THE COUNTLESS PEOPLE THAT
HE- ATTACHED AS A COACH AND A
TEACHER. BUT THE BROADER
COMMUNITY IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
WILL MISS HIM DEARLY FOR HE WAS
A- WONDERFUL INDIVIDUAL WHO
TOUCHED THE LIVES OF SO MANY
STUDENTS FAMILIES OF THE
BASEBALL. OF FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE THAT WAS. REBORN ABER
SAT AT HIS LOSS AND WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO JOIN WITH SO MANY
IN FRESNO AND IN THE FRESNO
CITY. COLLEGE FAMILY IN.
LEADING COACH FLOWS FAMILY KNOW
THAT. WE ARE MORNING WITH THEM.
WE ARE SO SAD TO SEE THIS
HAPPEN. BUT HE LEAVES A LEGACY
OF A LIFE WELL LIVED AND
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BETTER OFFER TOUCHING
HIS LIFE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER PATTERSON MR BRO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. ARISE TO CHURN THE
MEMORY OF GENERAL JOHN KERRY
DAVIS A LONG TIME SAN CLEMENTE
RESIDENT AND FORMER ASSISTANT
COMMANDANT UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS. WHO DIED AT THE AGE OF
NINETY TWO. GENERAL DAVIS WAS A
TIRED HIGHLY DECORATED FOUR
STAR GENERAL WHO SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINES FROM
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. BORN MARCH
FOURTEENTH NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN IN NEW MEXICO. GENERAL
DAVIS GRADUATED FROM
ALBUQUERQUE HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AND
IMMEDIATELY ENLISTED IN THE
MARINE CORPS RESERVES YOUR THE
BACHELOR DEGREE IN SOCIAL
STUDIES FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEW MEXICO IN NINETEEN FIFTY.
AND A MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION FROM GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE GENERAL
DAVIS WAS A HIGHLY DECORATED.
VIETNAM VETERAN ENABLE EIGHTY
AVIATOR. HE SERVED AS THE
COMMANDING GENERAL OF THE THIRD
MARINE AIRCRAFT WING FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND THE
FIRST MARINE AIRCRAFT WING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HIS
FINAL ASSIGNMENT WAS ASSISTANT
COMMANDANT OF THE MARINE CORPS
FROM. NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. ANY TIRES
A FOUR STAR GENERAL. OVER HIS
MILITARY CAREER. HERE IN
SIXTEEN AWARDS INCLUDING THE
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE MEDAL
DEFENSE SUPERIOR SERVICE MEDALS
LEGION OF MERIT AND
DISTINGUISHED FLYING CROSS.
GENERAL DAVIS FLEW MORE THAN
THIRTY DIFFERENT AIRCRAFT IN
THE MARINES AND FLEW TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE COMBAT
HOURS. IN VIETNAM A HUNDRED
SIXTY AT NIGHT AND HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE COMBAT MISSIONS OF
THOSE ONE HUNDRED WERE AT NIGHT.
HE WAS A MEMBER THE SENATE
COMMITTEE EXCHANGE CLUB IN A
LONG TIME MEMBER OF SEVERAL
MARINE CORPS AND AVIATION
ASSOCIATIONS INCLUDING THE
GOLDEN EAGLES GENERAL DAVIS
ALSO LIKE TO PLAY GOLF EVERY
WEDNESDAY. AND SANK MANY
MUNICIPAL. THE FAMILY
CELEBRATED HIS NINETY SECOND
BIRTHDAY IN MARCH AND MORE THAN
A HUNDRED PEOPLE ATTENDED HIS
PARTY HE LOVED THE MARINES IN
HIS FAMILY AND HIS FRIENDS. HE
ALWAYS HAD A GOOD STORY AND
REALLY LOOKED AT THE GOOD IN
PEOPLE SAID HIS DAUGHTER JULIE
OF HIS FATHER'S LEGACY. IT IS
RETIREMENT GENERAL DAVIS WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE DEVELOPMENT
THE MARINE MONUMENT. THAT PARK
SEMPER FI IN SAN CLEMENTE
DEDICATED IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
HIS LEGACY AN INSPIRATION WILL
LIVE ON. SEMPER FI FOR
COUNTLESS GENERATIONS TO COME.
AVIS LEAVES BEHIND THREE
DAUGHTERS JULIE GLENN AND KERRY
FIVE GRAND CHILDREN DAVIS'S
WIFE JANE PASSED AWAY TWO YEARS
AGO THE COUPLE HAD LIVED IN SAN
CLEMENTE FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS
SEMPER FI GENERAL DAVIS. AND
ASKED THAT WE JOURNEYS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER BRO
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS MORNING I'M A
DURING IN THE MEMORY A LONG
TIME CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SECOND WE'LL STAFFER
IT'S THE ISSUE BLACK ALONE
FOUNDER JACKIE MORSE ANDERSON
WHO PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
TWENTY SIXTH. MORE TO SYLVIA
JACQUELINE MORRIS IN
PHILADELPHIA ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTH NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
JACKIE WAS ACTUALLY HER
NICKNAME. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE JACK INTERSECT STATE THE
FRESHMEN AND THEY'RE BEGINNING
A CAREER OVER THREE DECADES OF
TIME WITH THE UNIVERSITY IF THE
STUDENT. STILL EMPLOYEE
GRADUATE AND STAFF MEMBER.
GRADUATING IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THE BACHELORS IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION JACKIE ALSO
LATER ON RECEIVED A BACHELOR'S
IN COMMUNICATIONS AND A MASTERS
IN HUMAN RESOURCES. AND
ORGANIZATION DEVELOPMENT. WHEN
A JACKIE'S GREATEST MOMENTS WAS
THE SALVATION OF THE BLACK
ALUMNI CHAPTERS SEXY. JACKIE
WAS ALSO INVOLVED IN THE
SECULAR COMMUNITY HELPING UP
LIFT OTHERS. SH BUT LEADERSHIP
SKILLS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CULTURAL ADVISORY COUNCIL HAS
GOAL SHOULD COMMITTEE THE
PROJECT REBOUND PROGRAM
COMMITTEE THE HAWK INSTITUTE
THE END OF LACI P. THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
WOMEN. JACK IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND DONALD HENDERSON HER
PARENTS JACK AND SYLVIA MORRIS
INNER SIBLINGS JOANNE MORRIS
AND DEL MORRIS. JACKIE WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO ALL OF US SHOULD
BE DEEPLY MISSED MY HEARTFELT
PRAYERS AND THOUGHTS GO TO
JACKIE'S FAMILIES AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO JOIN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR SECOND
INTERMEMBRANE. MORNING I'M
INJURED IN MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS I'LL BORROW AL
MORASS A FIREFIGHTER OF
SEVENTEEN YEARS THE CONSUMERS
FIRE DEPARTMENT MR MORASS WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN SACRAMENTO
IS A FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN
AL HAD A DISTINGUISHED
FIREFIGHTER WAS DISEASE
FIREFIGHTER TWO THOUSAND NINE
IS RECOGNIZED WITH THE FIRE
MARK AWARD FOR HIS WORK
DISTRIBUTES MOTOR TEXTURES TO
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING RESIDENTS
IN OUR COMMUNITY HE TAUGHT
FIRST DATE TO SACRAMENTO AREA
FARMWORKERS AND EVEN TRAINED
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE WESTERN
REGION OF MEXICO. I WAS ALSO AN
ACCOMPLISHED ATHLETE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE BATTLE OF
BADGES CHERRY BOXING PROGRAM IN
SACRAMENTO IT COULD BE IN THE
BOOK. ASPEN IS ENTIRE LIFE
HELPING OTHERS BOTH PERSONALLY
PROFESSIONALLY KNOWN AS DAYS
OFF UNPROFESSIONALLY. DESPITE
HIS MANY ACHIEVEMENTS AL'S
GREATEST ATTRIBUTES WERE SIMPLY
BEING THE MOST AMAZING FATHER
HUSBAND SON BROTHER UNCLE
FRIEND AND PAPA. ALBUM IS
DEEPLY MY THOUGHTS ARE WITH HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF JARED NATHANIEL ARNOLD HIS
LIFE WAS UNEXPECTEDLY CUT SHORT
ON AUGUST TENTH JUST NINE DAYS
AFTER CELEBRATING HIS FORTY
SECOND BIRTHDAY. JARED WAS THE
SIXTH CHILD BORN TO HIS PARENTS
STEVE AND MOAN ARNOLD. JR
GRADUATED FROM RANCHO BERNARDO
HIGH SCHOOL WITH HONORS AND HE
MADE HIS PARENTS PROUD DURING
HIS YOUTH WHEN HE DECIDED ON
HIS OWN TO WALK FOR CHARITIES
THAT RAISE MONIES TO SAVE THE
RAINFOREST ENDANGERED ANIMALS
AND THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS
FOUNDATION. IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE JERRY JARRETT JOINED A
FIVE OH ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT
GROUP CALLED ADOPTED CHURCH
WITH HIS FATHER AND SPENT TIME
IN MISSISSIPPI REBUILDING
CHURCHES AND HOMES AFTER THE
DISASTER OF HER CANE KATRINA.
WHEN THE WHICH CREEK FIRE HIT
THE COMMUNITY OF RANCHO
BERNARDO IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
MANY FAMILIES WERE SLEEPING IN
THEIR HOMES AND JARED HELPED
WITH EVACUATING HIS NEIGHBORS.
HIS WORK WITH THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES INSTALLING COLD
STEAM SYSTEMS AND HUNDREDS OF
NURSERIES AND DATE FRUIT FARMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING THAT
COMMUNITY HE WAS A MAN WITH AN
INCREDIBLE WORK ETHIC AND
DESIRE FOR PERFECTION WHICH
FUELED HIS CONTINUING EDUCATION
AND CERTIFICATION FIRST
PROFESSION WHICH IN TURN
CREATED A HUGE DEMAND FOR
SERVICES. IS WITH A HEAVY HEART
THAT I ASKED WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF JARED NATHANIEL
ARNOLD. THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO DEATH TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. OUR
QUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER AYE IS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED THE
ROUTINES. ALMOST TEN YEARS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO INTEREST
IN MOTION TO ADJOURN. MR BONTA
MOVES IN A SERRANO SECONDS.
THIS HOUSE STANDS. ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY SEPTEMBER NINTH AT
ONE PM